I wanna meet the
people risking everything.
You ever been on camera?
It's like high school all over again.
And see just how far
they will go for their cause.
What can people like me do
to help out a situation like this?
Listen.
Say that again.
Listen, okay.
We're tryin' to deal
with our PTSD in a positive way.
This is therapy.
How 'bout a book club?
This is safer than war.
That is fair.
You're going
to see this courage
of people puttin' their body on the line.
We just capsized.
I used to be behind a desk.
Just feels like we
should be more empathetic
to those people who have made the choice
to serve for this country.
But, tough titties?
Yeah, tough titties.
Cold.
I don't look at you
and see you as oppressed.
When you
have to get permission
to exercise a right --
That's oppression.
Georgia is by far
the worst state to live in
if you're undocumented.
So, we're number one.
In discrimination.
You might wanna leave that off.
Maybe this is where I belong.
I've been told
I have a face for radio.
- You do.
With people
willing to risk everything.
You guys are under arrest
We're getting arrested.
Is there any way to stand beside you,
but courageously sit down
a little bit in the back?
Haha, no, no.
No.